halli hallo
hallo tom du hast uns gefunden super
hallo ich bin der christoph dahin
ja
wie ist die lage mein arsch tut weh beim
was ist das für ein auto es ist ein
recht bequem ist autor aber sechs
stunden im auto dann ist irgendwann mal
finish kennst du das auch dass der
einschläft ja es ist einfach ein 1 1 ein
schmerz also ich weiß aber eingeschlafen
ist aber es geht erholt sich langsam
wieder also mir schläft er dann ein das
ist wie ein eingeschlafener fuß und dann
der ganze hintern und das ist nicht
schön da mal pause gemacht aber das
bringt dann nicht wirklich für das ist
bleibt der zustand dann erst mal du bist
zum zweiten mal in köln so zweiten mal
ja genau kommst du denn ansonsten öfter
mal raus da man stellt sich ja das davor
da ist irgendwo das ende der welt dann
kommt lange gar nichts und dann ist das
da wo du wohnst und so findest du mich
genauso hast du sagst du hast es
geschrieben genauso ist es also es ist
eigentlich es ist gar nichts sind links
kühn rechts schweine und aber es ist
schön also ich bin gerne mal in
großstädten aber wenn ich dann wieder
abends zu hause bin und meine who hat
bin ich auch immer weiß ich immer dass
ich dann da hingehört und ich wohne ja
und so steht er doch ist schon so ist
das nicht vermisst man nicht eben die
dicke disco oder so nachtleben und party
und also da bin ich sowieso nicht so ein
selten partygänger also das habe ich
nicht so oft und nun also man hat da so
seine freunde man macht dann halt mehr
mit mit mit freunden oder wenn man dann
halt hier so viele möglichkeiten hat
irgendwas anderes zu machen dann hat man
da eine ganz tolle gemeinschaft die
wieder haben so unter unter freuen und
deswegen ist das vermisse ich also nicht
okay wie schlägt man länder die zeit tot
mit bekloppten videos machen
ja doch also das ist eigentlich das was
man machen kann und dann die anderen mit
animieren und dann geht es los wie ist
das entstanden
das ist entstanden dass ich eigentlich
was für freunde machen wollte oder oder
mit freunden zusammen wie diesmal haben
wollte wenn wir mal irgendwo privat
gefeiert haben habe ich das dann
aufgenommen und dann habe ich das online
gestellt und dann haben sie sich gesagt
das kannst du ganz gut dass das liegt ja
irgendwie das unseren kleinen sohn witz
reinzubringen und dann habe ich das
weiter verfolgt und ja irgendwann kam
dann das video das dann auch mal so
nicht nur meine freundin gesehen haben
sondern ein bisschen mehr leute und so
fing das sagen ja welches war das es war
dieses deutschland sucht den superstar
video da habe ich mich darüber beschwert
dass rtl die ganzen videos sperrt von
von dsds auf youtube und das war
natürlich dieser suchbegriff dsds wird
natürlich tausendfach eingegeben und das
habe ich ganz unbewusst gemacht und auf
einmal war das ist ein riesen halb der
da irgendwie entstanden ist das war ganz
lustig macht sich ja nicht erschrocken
da habe ich mich im ersten moment schon
erschrocken also dass das also gerade
dieses video das ding halt sehr auf
einmal ging das los so nah und da dachte
ich schon so hahaha das ist ja ganz
schön extremzone aber es ging dann die
videos danach waren wir so ein bisschen
weniger und so konnte man sich so
langsam so darauf darauf vorbereiten das
war ganz okay aber inzwischen bist du
auch kult
wenn du dass du sagst du ja also immer
kenn dich mein agent sandra man kann
sagen
wie bist du auf die idee gekommen also
wie auch wieder die blöde frage da bist
du irgendwo im nirgendwo
aber auch im nirgendwo gibt es einige
mädchen wo man so denkt ja ja ja ja ja
und dann dann sucht man sich so ein paar
sachen raus bei den songs die das
ausmacht so und dann dann steht eine
sandra und dann hat man die irgendwie
dieses leicht naive zügige aber dann
doch wieder irgendwie was lebenswert ist
dass diese vision verwirrend macht und
dann ja dann ist sie da trotzdem meine
frage gibt es da nicht zu wenig input
ich meine wenn man da in die weite guckt
die seen oder was sonst in deinem video
zoom.in der guten flüge da fehlt gibt so
viel gegen bei dir das stimmt also mir
hat es noch nicht also ich habe das
nicht gemerkt dass mir da irgendwas
irgendwas fehlt also es war immer so
dass ich immer noch irgendwie eine idee
hatte und das entsteht meistens wenn ich
dann wir haben ja auch kleinere städte
dann so bei uns in der ecke und da sieht
man ja auch mal leute und man kommt ja
auch im fernsehen das haben wir
mittlerweile auch da eine ecke und
da kriegt man ja auch ganz viel
operation was was da mittlerweile so
läuft da ist ja eigentlich nur noch zu
fassen was da teilweise gezeigt werde
das kann man ja gar nicht anders sagen
sag' dir das denn schon immer so was zu
machen oder bist du erst durch youtube
und diese möglichkeiten darauf gekommen
also dass ich irgendwie sowieso ein
kleines talent habe irgendwie so leute
zu unterhalten das hatte ich schon als
ich ich weiß nicht wie alt ich da war
szenen da waren meine eltern im legoland
haben wir gewonnen und dann war da ein
riesengroßer speisesaal mit meiner ich
weiß es selber nicht meine eltern haben
mir erzählt mit hunderten von leuten war
da eine bühne und da war ein mikrofon
und auf einmal war klein torge weg und
wir haben gesucht wo es hat den usa denn
da auf einmal hörte meine stimme ruhig
habe irgendwas gesungen also vor diesen
vor diesen leuten da habe ich schon
gesagt ja ja ja ja ist denn das und dann
ging das in der grundschule so weiter
dass ich dann da den zirkusdirektor
gespielt habe und ja so entwickelt sich
das dann in der realschule ja und von
daher das war schon immer so dass ich
das was ich das irgendwie ausleben
musste das irgendwie raus musste und
jetzt habe ich mit youtube habe ich da
ganz gut ist ventil gefunden um das mal
so ein bisschen so auch eine größere
öffentlichkeit zu bringen wie soll das
weitergehen
weißt du ich mir eigentlich nicht so
viele gedanken weil im moment ist
youtube das macht mir spaß da kann ich
das machen was ich was was mir auch spaß
macht ich bin sozusagen mein eigener
chef ich kann - online stellen wenn ich
das möchte und von daher
ich mache mir da keinen kopf also im
moment ist es schön bissig genießt das
so und so von mir aus kann es so bleiben
denn die meiste zeit damit verbringt
oder was ist eine hauptbeschäftigung
eine hauptbeschäftigung ist ja es ist
zum größten teil schon youtube dass man
immer immer mal guckt das ist im
hobbymäßig im musical mache ich mache
ich bei mir also eine kleine musical
gemeinschaft liebe grüße auch du singst
nein weil die ge stimme klingt nicht wie
die eine sänger nein das ist auch es
geht gerade es reicht fürs dorf
erst recht das dorf aber dann ist auch
gut und der rest der zeit machst du
irgendwas beruflich bin noch eine
ausbildung ja und mache jetzt im
sozialpädagogischen bereich was
und das war schon fünf jahre
dann muss ich meine jetzt auch noch
irgendwie du machst fünf jahren eine
ausbildung immer fünf jahren ausbildung
als sind zwei verschiedene es ist eine
ausbildung dauert zwei jahre und die
andere dauert drei jahre und was bist du
am ende dann will ich jetzt hier
erzieher und das möchtest du auch gerne
das möchte ich gerne wieder hier hat
youtube so eine andere richtung noch
gebracht wo man denkt mir war das
eigentlich immer klar dass ich
eigentlich so was machen möchte nur ich
habe nicht so richtig die die richtige
ecke gefunden was mir so wenn man wenn
man irgendwie eine zeit im musical dass
er singen tanzen das ist reicht auch
nicht so theater ich weiß nicht auf so
einer bühne jeden abend das gleiche
machen aber es wäre ich gesagt ja macht
man erstmal erzieherin dann bist du erst
mal dass man vielleicht öffnet sich
irgendwann mal eine andere tür und so
sehe ich das jetzt auch ich mache jetzt
erzieher ich mach youtube und wenn da
irgendwas mehr entsteht wo ich dann
irgendwann mal sagen so jetzt habe ich
jetzt hier gemacht hat kann ich mal eine
andere richtung einschlagen dann mach
ich das vielleicht einfach noch mal bist
du vielleicht auch zum beispiel für
jemand der es eben wahrscheinlich in
keinem casting geschafft hätte ja
wahrscheinlich ja also denke ich schon
dass ich da nicht so
nicht so der typ verbinden ich glaube
ich hätte mich auch nie beworben also
ich hätte auf dem mut nicht gehabt da
will ich so ein stiller held in tallinn
ehre die ich noch nicht gemacht ist
youtube das ist manchmal meinen eindruck
so eine plattform die leute
ich sag jetzt mal ist ein blödes wort
aber vielleicht beschreibt dass es doch
ganz gut nach oben spült
die sonst untergegangen wären ja erst
kann gut sein man merkt es ja auch mal
man im anstellten video online man fängt
ja bei null anfängt aber du machst einen
du machst einen channel fängst an als
neue abonnenten text gut mal gucken was
passiert du packst ein video rein
und mit glück währt gucken sie sich ein
paar an und dann merkst du schon die
ersten reaktionen so und dann christoph
bergner weise okay kommt das ankommt das
nächste an was er dann vielleicht von
zehn zwölf leuten und du hast es lieber
von denen das ist scheiße ist als wenn
du dir ins fernsehen lesen dass der von
und millionen krieges mit hast du das
absolut nicht ganz deswegen ist es doch
schon man kann ein bisschen
mutiger sein da sein talent vielleicht
auch anders entwickeln weil man viel
öfter und schneller und mehr
rückkopplung bekommen sie ja ja klar und
auch weil du bei youtube du kannst ja
alles machen du kannst ja wirklich von
von a bis b kannst du dich ja
ausprobieren was hier liegt und bist du
im fernsehen dann gehst du dahin als ja
jetzt kommen wir die typ dahin und dann
musste witzig sein und dann will man
sich auch eigentlich nicht so gern in
der andere sparte sehen und bei youtube
ist es schon sagt man dann auch mal
sagen kann als ein versuch ist es
wirklich mal dass du ein bisschen was
mit musik wie schon weniger und hier und
da das ist ganz gut da bist du damit
glücklich sehr glücklich wer kann aber
auch ohne glaube ich noch also ich hatte
ein schickes leben vor youtube das hat
war toll mit youtube ist es auch toll es
wird natürlich was fehlen ganz klar das
ist macht super viel spaß zu machen aber
ich glaube es wird auch ohne gehen ja
aber ist es nicht so dass man da auch
einfach eine super bestätigung bekommt
will ich das ganz toll fürs
selbstbewusstsein er wenn man sich dann
dass das durchliest es ist natürlich
etwas ganz tolles also und viele nette
leute da also wobei es geht ja auch
andersrum es geht natürlich auch andere
auch die anlage christ ist auch
knallhart da ist nur ein video ist mist
dann bist du gleich dann kann das ganz
schnell vorbei sein also dass die
knallharte also das ist ja auch weil du
die rechte kommentaren unter ließen du
siehst dass das kann abgestimmt werden
ist das jetzt gut ist es nicht gut und
von daher das geht ganz fix entweder
bist bist du supermann video das nächste
video keinen grund schlecht sein und
dann denkst dir aus der gott und da
zögern die ja auch nicht mit
die drücken es nicht so soll ich sagen
ja es ist keine konstruktive kritik sage
ich mal die dann kommt weiß da gibt für
super satz zu die kommentar qualität auf
youtube ist niedrig ja das hast du sehr
schön auch später christoph das ist auch
so sehr niedrig aber was kannst du das
ganz gut verknusen oder ist das dann
immer wie ein schlag in die magengrube
also und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
dass ich noch nicht so
noch nicht so hat damit konfrontiert
wurde auch also ich hatte bis jetzt
immer ganz ganz viel glück mit meinen
videos eigentlich und mit meinen sachen
ideen die ich hatte und von daher
ja ich warte da nicht drauf das ist
passiert aber irgendwann wird es
sicherlich mal passieren ich gucke mir
das ist ich weiß es nicht ja ok ja das
ist ja gut wenn man sollen
genauso ist da jetzt trotzdem an dieser
stelle nochmal du hast ja wahrscheinlich
gedanken schon gemacht und vielleicht
auch mal mit deinen eltern gesprochen
oder
ist es im moment noch so hey ich werde
erzieher das für youtube kann nur ein
hobby sein weil ich sag mal bei anderen
youtube
du bist ja auch unter den top youtube an
da ist es schon so dass das eigentlich
fast also sagen wir mal ich wüsste jetzt
nicht dass sie mir irgendwas anderes
macht als youtube videos und ich glaube
das funktioniert auch hast du da schon
mal in die richtung gedacht oder ist
dass so etwas wo du vielleicht lieber
noch nicht dran denken ist oder
ich versuche dann nicht daran zu denken
weil ich glaube wenn ich mir jetzt pläne
schmiedet und dann guckt dann könnte das
passieren dann könnte das passieren da
habe ich so viele abonnenten und das
passiert dann nicht glaube dann bin ich
ganz schön enttäuscht und das lasse ich
dann lieber im moment sage ich mir so du
wirst jetzt erzieher du machst das und
wenn sich die chance ergibt dann schlägt
sie zu und dann versuchst es einfach
weil es dann nicht wenn es dann nicht
klappt ist auch nicht so name ist
versucht aber ich setze mir jetzt kein
festes ziel ist das möchte ich einfach
nicht das ist
also du bist nicht der typ ich kann mich
jetzt ein halbes jahr da voll rein und
mal gucken alles auf die zwölf so
würdest du nicht ins risiko gehen also
lieber das ist so funktioniert und
irgendwann so populär bist dass du sagst
kommen jetzt
funktioniert das ist das andere mir
fehlen da auch einfach die dann die
ideen für wirklich zu sagen dass ich in
der woche mal zwei videos hochladen das
dass das schaffe ich nicht oder dann
sind viele ideen da ich dreh viel an
videos aber hat dann auch ganz viel von
rechnern ruhig sagt habe ich ihm nicht
mehr zufrieden und das lasse ich dann
drauf und deswegen dann sag ich lieber
ich mache lieber alle zwei wochen machen
wie du rein immer einen guten abstellen
wo ich dann auch sagen kann wo ich
selber damit zufrieden und sagen kann ja
da stehe ich jetzt auch zu das ist so
wie das ist und wo ich auch gefühl habe
dass das gut ankommen wird und so ist
man das dann lieber wobei man könnte es
ja auch ich sag mal du kannst mit leuten
zusammenarbeiten die für dich zum
beispiel schreiben könnte der unter
freunden machen du könntest die taktzahl
ja einfach mal da öl könnte weil das
will ich jetzt mal als außenstehender
sagen du bist schon ein typ der für die
comedy bühne geeignet ist das wirst du
ja auch schon gehört haben oder erzählt
man ihr das da oben im norden nicht weil
du keinen trifft der leser sagen doch
das erzählt man mir schon dass ich noch
ganz nett von den 1 aber ich versuche es
trotzdem nicht auch wenn ich weiß ich
könnte vielleicht dann den hebel in
bewegung setzen dann würde sich das
ergeben und dies und dies könnte ich
machen aber
ich bin im moment so glücklich ich weiß
irgendwann gar nicht wie das wird es
dann weitergehen soll also es ist es ist
einfach so toll wie es im moment ist und
das macht mir super viel spaß und
es ist somit dem mit dem erkennen auf
der straße dass ich so sache das ist das
gefällt mir noch alles das ist doch so
im rahmen und von mir auch so zu bleiben
es ist einfach gut um ja bald wird nicht
so bleiben also für mich wirkt jetzt auf
jemals so ein bisschen als wirt zu
schwimmen als wüsstest du nicht ganz
genau in welches universums ich hatte
mir beide ist offen so das ist der
erzieher der dahin geht und das ist dann
der der der youtuber oder der komet typ
der in die andere richtung geht und das
zerreißt sich nicht
moment noch nicht kann aber
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal kommen
wenn dann da wenn so ein paar mehr
abonnenten da sind und dann
werden sie auch mehr leute sagen wenn
ich mach es doch mach es doch versucht
doch wenigstens einfach mal aber im
moment noch nicht was sagen wenn die
freunde
die freunde sagen
warum es meistens dass die in meiner
klasse sagen oder die lehrer zu mir
sagen was machst du eigentlich hier so
manche machen auch in einer klasse mal
so kleine schultheater sachen und so was
machst du hier und dass du passt hier
nicht hin und ging nach hamburg auf
irgend eine schauspielschule oder sowas
aber
noch nicht ist das vielleicht doch im
nachteil wenn man da irgendwo im
nirgendwo lebt das kann sagt man nicht
so ich bin auch sehr heimat heimat
orientiert da in der ecke das ist die
viele verstehen ist immer gar nicht was
ich sagen so toll finde aber ich finde
diese ecke in der wiederum die iss hat
so etwas liebevolles und schönes und
deswegen es kann sein wenn ich in
hamburg aufgewachsen wir dass ich dann
schon von anfang an gesagt hat okay die
schule nebenan da hab da willst du hin
da kennst du das kannst du aber
im moment nicht hast du angst vor der
weiten welt
bisschen klar
jetzt wollen wir jetzt fehlt hast du
mich der blick auch hass angst vor der
welt
ja es ist natürlich ein bisschen
natürlich klar habe ich das und ich muss
gucken wo mich das womit das hin trägt
und im moment habe ich das so dass ich
in meiner kleinen welt
das machen kann dass ich
bekanntheitsgrad irgendwo habe das
gefällt mir trotzdem komme ich aber auch
gerne mal nach köln um so ein tolles
interview mit ihm zu machen
und nachher mit diesem schönen treffen
noch und wie schon gesagt bin aber auch
froh wenn ich wieder zu hause bin dann
gut nochmal ein stückchen draufgelegt
gibt es nicht leute die sagen du feierst
miststück kolleg warum machst du es
nicht du hast nur weiß genau dass das
ganz du musst das machen es ist ein
verlust für die menschheit wenn du nicht
langsam in gang hochschalten es gibt ja
eine lehrerin die das macht ja eine
ehemalige lehrer eine ganz nette und die
hat dann hat mir das mal wir auch so
gesagt der gesagt du wirst das bereuen
nachher du wirst es bereuen und mach es
doch mach es doch und hau ab hier und so
weiß nicht ob ich das stuhr bin ich weiß
nicht ob das richtig ist ob ich was ob
ich wenn ich das so mache hat der hat ja
gesagt dass du bequem bist das hat sie
mir auch gesagt ja ich bin da sehr
bequem
ja so ist es ja ja nein bequem will ich
auch motivieren ja ist ja auch nett von
dir ich bin halt so ein youtube fan was
ich das ebenso sensationell finde das
eben solche leute wie du die vor 20
jahren nie eine chance gehabt hätten die
werden würden das ist jetzt gemein wenn
ich das sage die würden irgendwo
versauern und
deswegen finde ich deine lehrerin eine
ehemalige sensationell wie kann der gar
nicht genug in hintern treten
weil ich das toll finden wenn leute von
sich aus das schaffen und nicht weil sie
geputzt und marketing und pr und
sonstwas und alle denken mein gott ein
blöder kerl aber gut jetzt gucken uns
alle danken ist auch und das ist bei dir
nicht der fall sondern es ist du
überzeugt alle mit dem was du machst von
0 eben wie du selber gesagt hast und
dann
nicht auch der meinung seiner lehrerin
du musst zu packen du hast eine
einmalige chance ja und die musst du
nutzen
ok ich will deine antwort hören
ich gehe würde dieselbe antwort will ich
den bereits vor einigen minuten gegeben
habe
meine damen und herren hiermit ist das
interview beendet in welche kamera
so fest trotzdem gerne dann heute abend
oder morgen wieder zurück ich fahre sehr
gerne wieder zurück was ist denn da so
schön da oben im
es ist einfach tolle menschen da sind so
tolle freunde die man da hat und
es ist die landschaft da die nordsee ist
so schön und
ja ich kann es nicht beschreiben man
muss da einfach mal ein paar ein paar
wochen verbringen und dann es ist dass
viele gehen weg auch nach australien
ganz viele nach hamburg und das ist
unglaublich wie viele wieder zurück
kommen und sagen es ist so schön ich
weiß nicht was es ist aber
ich komme immer wieder gerne hier und
die ziehen dann immer wieder dahin ihr
seid keine fischköppe darum das sagt man
ja den norddeutschen ein bisschen nach
also ich hätte dich fischköppe sind
leute mit nun muss man eigentlich 50
jahre befreundet sein bis sie dann mal
das du anbieten
ich nutze die schon mit deinen eltern
der seit gestern erst hatte gesagt ich
habe noch keine okay wir bieten dir dass
du es doch ja
es gibt da einige so und man merkt es
auch dass hier in der andere stimmung
ist als als manchmal da oben aber die
clique die wir haben es ist halt eine
musical clique und das ist auch theater
und die sind ja alle ein bisschen ist
nicht böse gemeint aber ist es ja nun
mal so und und die pädagogen die haben
auch alle einander luke und von daher
sind wir da schon echt gut drauf und
machen die ordentlich ohne stimmung in
der ecke ja doch gut gut also dann freue
ich mich auf weiter gute stimmung aus
der ecke wünschen dir aber trotzdem dass
du irgendwann der schuh einer ehemaligen
lehrerin so spitz wird das du los muss
er in die weite welt und da würde ich
mich auch riesig freuen ich freue mich
über beides ich glaube das tun alle die
jetzt suchen auch dann kommen wird danke
christa weil heute